before this term microaggression was
introduced six months ago did you ever
have things that you would run up
against where you were like ah I just
wish that white people stopped doing X
yeah all the time like what meth big
reveal who don't know he sent this out I
believe to all of his staffers he did
yeah
the microaggression test Oh but gig
that's good so I want to know if anyone
else we did the white privilege survey a
while back so questions they have any of
you ever taken or been forced to take
from your HR department at your office a
microaggressions test and what did you
score I try and set the high score yes
[Laughter]
so I think it's lost on youth not here
with your iPhone's and your tic TOCs so
this comes from Pete butt-kick who's
obviously been struggling with black
voters I wonder what - the man is
positively translucent and this was sent
out a survey on microaggressions in the
workplace so thank the Lord for the New
York Times because I know you print this
out apparently on a 1997 Xerox mission
goody baby oldie but goodie and this is
men - it says here so I want you guys to
all take it we have the link I believe
in the description ok survey
microaggressions in the workplace please
only fill out the survey if you identify
as a person of color identified hey I
actually identify as white really yeah
we will never accept you amongst our
ranks the seller isn't it it's a shade
how dare you sir but the answers are
anonymous and will be used to inform our
white colleagues about privilege and
microaggressions it's not going to the
[ __ ] question how did they decide
which ones were white or not white and
this is a legitimate question it is if
they have to self-identify that meant
they went around to everyone and they
said you okay should you get this email
or or should you not get this email and
we should know that the answers are A+
- of about 19% because Rachel Dolezal
was counted four times
every time every time any Iowa nielsie
15 yeah but you know what
hats off to her she really committed to
it was the weave all right so we will
all answer it considering that we only
identify as people of color which is
about a legitimate is someone
identifying as a biological female but
hey your rule is not out less I'm
primarily going to focus on the two
people of color quarter black Garrett
and half asian layer bill Richman thank
you you made an infinitely more Asian
than he looks black yeah that's for sure
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
first this is this is not a beneath the
service in the workplace have you ever
experienced the following from a white
colleague appreciate you uniting America
experience from a white colleagues
exactly what I really being interrupted
or talked over yes both I've never never
not experienced that but what have you
had been interrupted by not a white
colleague then it's what happens there
the universe explodes and everyone votes
for Trump screw my rules
yeah I want everyone to answer this
because you know I'm white and Gerald
you're very white and then audio wait is
I mean you're whiter than butt kick yeah
yeah can we answer the question in two
ways I want everyone to answer the
question both with the with from a white
colleague but also from a non-white
colleague right because I'm fairly
certain I've done every one of these two
Gerald twice today by the way as far as
II interrupted it's happened I would say
100% of my female college Gerald stop
interrupting let's see show of hands
I've all been interrupted in there
who here's been an up trade by
exclusively white colleagues really
learning something about herself
surround myself with ok the
introspection is amazing through line
here what did you say nothing
trust him to anything that he says that
goes out the air just bleep in here and
a certain side of caution in the
workplace I've ever experienced the
following from a white colleague have
you ever been left off a relevant email
chain said when I said well you know
this wouldn't have been a question until
Obama phone lady it's true there's a
bomber phone lady Oh
turns out she was rather than but the
dated reven I'd have to check my email
no how do you do that on this paper
there's some Angeles okay has anyone
here ever been left off a relevant email
chain yeah well you were left off how do
you know you know people leave myself oh
here you go guys just handle it I'll be
back all of us were left off of the
email change at some point yes yes in
the workplace have you ever experienced
the following from a white colleague I
have to read this every single time to
make sure not invited to a meeting
directly related to your job that
happens all the time
accidentally yeah yeah and what's
directly related I hate to parse words
here or like to try to dig deep in Delhi
don't do it merriam-webster shut up I
actually do I'm gonna take that all back
and say Gerald you do have a crack point
which is what does invite to a meeting
directly related job that directly is it
related who's deciding is really yeah is
everything that goes not exactly your
way survey yes with the boss well no
this is the boss can't be white because
it will be merely discard it would do it
correct
people know you're asking for people to
have a problem alright so show of hands
who's ever been not accidentally or or
premeditated white people against me I'm
telling how it happens now let me ask
you quarterback Garrett and half-asian
bill any of these so far these three do
you feel like they were due to your race
yes yeah I do
justification well when I was I was
leading a professional organization of
Asian attorneys that would frequently
leave me out because I'm half white okay
next one in the workplace of your
experience the [ __ ] have you ever
experienced the following from a white
colleague in case people just tuning in
the idea your idea was ignored dismissed
without explanation that's a different
topic Indian or Steven entirely does
specifically it was in the contract that
we signed beyond the show Pete mayor
Pete has never listened to any ideas I
think this is just this is in like these
questions if the answers are really yes
and they're exclusive too it's because
you're in a crappy workplace because
yeah I do feel as though Oh like we
don't take all ideas of course like in
the rule of comedy you know out of ten
bits that you may write or if we do a
meet cigarette and one finally makes it
to air but we pretty much hear
everyone's ideas right yes yeah and you
laugh at them and mock them mercilessly
if they're not itself becomes funny is
this written for like the front office
of the Klan like it's a black person
context matters Pete but like why was
that item up there has to answer these
questions i right all right
again the survey people just tuning in
microaggressions in the workplace in the
workplace have you ever experienced the
following from a white colleague someone
else taking credit for your idea or
insight even accidentally well how could
you know accidentally my idea
yeah burgers every day for breakfast we
don't even have a cafeteria motorized
cart yes exactly and I stole it he was
trying to get another sponsorship just
to bring in the burgers so you could
have someone else taking credit for your
idea or insight just they're so vague I
don't understand like yeah stuff like
this happens to everybody every day I
will say this I am always very concerned
we were just tell me this with audio
wait and that long ago before run
through where you guys will be watching
the clips and when you'll run through
before the show where we look at the
clips to make sure the ID levels are
right and read sure that our talking
points are proper and at least that
we're informed a lot of this it's not
run on prompter like right now there is
no perks or not on Fox nation but you
often will come up with like a quip
watching a clip you know just written
and it's funny hey remember that
remember that because there are times
where I might remember that bringing it
on air and you don't and then I use it
yeah and now because I never want to be
that guy who takes and guess the death
glare it's like provin it was funny you
take credit for yeah you do you do you
do not aware of it because of your
glasses
they're like magnifying glasses into
your empty soul
it's a shark's idea Bissell okay I mean
I guess I mean pretty much we're gonna
go through these because we still have a
segment to do but they're all gonna be
yes have you in the workplace of your
experience of falling from a white
colleague been called the name of a
different staff member of color yes
Bruce Lee in a meeting as Carl and Kim
Jong bill so yes that's because you
handed out name cards I did they said
Carl yeah it was in called the name of a
different staff member of color hmm wait
does that just mean if you if anyone
ever works at your okay can I can I
actually give you a good example of this
so my mom is from Hong Kong
so she speaks Chinese in Chinese the
same word there's one word for he and
she you just you it's just
gender-neutral unity was a train
gender thing I have no idea I have no
property my Fuhrer but I will never show
yes I will bring her on the show and she
in sight but so sometimes like that's
gross for a while she sometimes get
confused and miscommunicate the pronouns
and I've often thought that if she was
ever in a situation where she had to
deal with someone's new pronouns that
her head would explode yeah but but by
the same token like when you think of
folks who are you attribute in your mind
what someone looks like and if you're
dealing with the same person over and
over again your mind just says okay I
differentiate these person and he's very
very block type ways yeah and I give
them this name if someone comes in and
has substantially the same very visible
block features you're going to sometimes
get those things confused and I've had
colleagues who are my own orders who
would say it's not uncommon yeah we do
it with white people all the races I saw
a man a quick trip who looked just like
50 cent see there you go but it was but
it was I think I told you that I said he
goes what or what cuz I'm black I said
no he's like no I'm just kidding I get
it all what does here's a question this
is that concludes the box check oh this
is good okay now we're in good Ally ship
look like to you what does good Ally
ship feel like quarterblack carry your
God you know every time I come into work
I like to see a watermelons oh boy
presents it to me and fried chicken
that's how I know you guys are so racist
boy that Kido phase was sure short-lived
yes it was his fried chicken not kitto
friendly French even is fine I think
well no there you gotta go buddy go
grill yeah what about you bill
what does good Ally ship feel like I
could be fry not setting me conserve and
further highlighting the difference
between me and someone else based on my
[ __ ] skin cut right
crazier about minded being like hey look
I need to get all of you okay how are
you gonna decide to define us well
here's a color palette here on this side
go to that room and if you're on this
side go to that room well but but
actually I grew up in the you know like
I grew up in this area that was like
really really nice and I have nothing in
common and I never experienced a these
hardships shut the [ __ ] up go over there
check the box and you feel that people
aren't listening to you because of your
race no because what I'm saying is so
good and they're stupid and foolish
nothing to do with the skin how can how
can you say that there's a survey meant
to help people look at the content of
the character again harkening back to
MLK and yet all you're focused on is the
skin tone what does good Ally should
feel like I'll put down like a warm hug
yeah I would like to to pat on the back
to know what I should release the hug
well I think this is redundant because
you just answered it what does bad Ally
ship look like service it seems like
yeah but kicking his staff surveys
alright what does Ally ship in the
workplace look like to you oh my god
okay I'm just gonna say this and it's
not directed at anyone personally but
it's bringing enough water into the
office and putting it in the fridge I
agree with this yes filling the water
cooler then right filling the water
cooler that's a good one it's a good one
yeah destroy the relationship that's
true yeah you like the plastic bottles
you and Chris Pratt look like what is
bad Ally should look like what does
allies ship in the workplace look like
to you so in other words you're asking
people about microaggressions in the
workplace but you're just asking them
about good Ally ship in general in life
yeah so because they don't know I'm so
gonna know that kid's gonna lose hard we
have two final questions this one is a
longer one again microaggressions and
the work that lady Bucky think of a
moment or moments during which you
experience microaggressions without
naming names of the people to be
anonymous and
without naming names of people can you
name the microaggression describe those
moments what was the physical
environment like it was hot if it
happened in the ether for example in
slack email or text is it Wow there was
like nothingness no they can have little
things in it right apparently slack
burger witnesses - it exists in the
in-betweens of the human dimension in
the gym its lack was coming identify
that were there witnesses to it and if
so do you think they recognized why is
the - there do can we show the - on the
camera no we should evident overlay will
happen do there's a - its whole surveys
after do shouldn't it be before do it
should be body away you're not at all
radical prick yes ok I only asked him
because he's the widest one here so I
assume he has stellar schooling is if he
wasn't here you would've that ready and
been told wrong if I lose a Rose Bowl
you'd be first we don't even play in the
Rose Bowl before enjoy well just depends
ok can you name the microaggression
Gerald breathing during those moments
what was the physical environment like a
garage duty ok let me ask you okay let
me actually try and frame this in
something but real I don't know I think
this is a totally invalid questionnaire
and I think that it divides people by
categories in there my race before this
term micro aggression was introduced six
months ago did you ever have things that
you would run up against where you were
like I just wish that white people
stopped doing X yeah all the time like
what meth
[Laughter]
no we did it right you guys just took it
to the wrong level going into Pearl
Harbor they're doing and just loitering
around a liquor store in all honesty
there is not a single thing that I could
say to you that I just see white people
doing right because inevitably with a
know if you meet enough people of any
other race you're gonna see those types
of people doing the same type of thing
that is disrespectful regardless of
their color right so maybe color of the
speaker right so if a white person says
they're not gonna listen to me it's
maybe it's because of my race maybe it's
not but you could meet another person of
another race and they're gonna go
Javanese Chinese are right oh you're not
the right kind of Chinese order I mean
there are people of all kinds of races
and that's why you got to get past that
that's not to say that there weren't
people doing racist things but that's
not everyone here's here's the thing and
to better serve our I didn't get any of
that but we'll make the translate demand
oh thank you here's the thing my I have
a step-brother he's full black he was
complaining about how he's always
followed in shopping centers and people
always suspicious about him I've been
pulled over and searched cap pulled out
of my car cuz you drive like it is hey
I've been searched like three times
he's never been by the way you don't
have to submit tell you don't submit
yourself to those searches if there's no
reasonable yeah but I'm saying be human
touch yeah really yeah but like he sees
it from a perspective of I'm black so
they are doing these things because I'm
black right not just I'm a person and
yeah he thinks happened to me because
I'm a person that's okay that there
aren't that the situation but every
single situation right reengineering to
condition people to see everything to
see lens right right does this happen
with exclusively white people and did
they do it because of your race this is
actually coaching people to ascribe
motive
you can't know what's accidental or not
and it's also confusing as hell because
identifying as a person of color how do
you identify
seriously I just they have to be careful
about that now because even though they
used to joke what how transracial isn't
a thing now they have to acknowledge I
think unless they lose a voting bloc
it's fine but it's a person of color
still right so you could say you're not
identifying you are 25% black yeah
that's not an identification that's
cracked right the server doesn't deal in
the realm affects an entirely deal in
the realm of conjecture and projection
let me give you an idea to their whole
side put it into context think about the
first time as a white person out there
or the black person honestly use as an
example you went to an Asian restaurant
like an authentic Chinese restaurant an
authentic I don't know Szechuan
restaurant I'll use because
chinese-american is kind of the mutters
the waters are kind of muddy yeah but
like everyone I went to a Szechuan
restaurant or Vietnamese restaurant for
the first time I didn't know anything so
if I'm confusing terms and I'm confusing
names and I'm asking I'm like well that
seems like the same thing I'm still
confused to say what the difference is
between a quesadilla and enchilada
I still need someone to coach me on it
that's just because we're exploring
cultures anytime you're exploring a new
culture or learning about a new culture
there's that impact point yeah where you
do have to go through the learning
process and guess what you're going to
be a little bit ignorant and now we are
dissuading people from actually curing
themselves of ignorance because the only
way to do that is to make mistakes the
only way to learn to ride a bike is to
make mistakes the only way to learn how
to read is to make mistakes you make
mistakes until you figure it out and it
doesn't mean that those mistakes are
hateful this is scary if an entire
generation of people are being raised on
this ideology right it's it's saying
just make sure you remember that if any
of these things ever happen to you it
was because of you're exactly exactly
100% because you are a color and they
are white yeah don't inquire any further
just remember it's you versus them right
and that's it's ridiculous is easy right
they do these two things don't walk
around looking to be offended in life
and don't walk around being a prick if
both of those things happen you're gonna
be just fine and it broke the great
Taylor Swift there's no such thing as a
prick that's true final question this
one I don't know I would argue seems a
little broad do you have anything else
to share we wanna merge that's the most
vague question I love this it's
literally like a FBI narc survey
do you have anyone here that you would
like to get thrown into a dungeon there
any other white people that you need to
tell on well mayor Pete well I don't
know anything else to share any other no
I mean I guess this is anything with
your mom
I'm just I'm just shocked that a a white
gay mayor well I'm a city that's
predominantly black is having a hard
time getting the black vote okay that's
that's just as well as the token white
patriarchy slash boss I will end it with
this I want to make sure that you
understand that I say this so I do have
something else to share and it has
nothing to do I do not attribute it at
all to half-asian bills race and I would
not Democrat an entire race of people
never because of the actions of one but
having Bill raped Gerald I wanted to get
that off my chest I know I know I am so
glad to and it's not because he's Asian
it's just a dominance thing if you
enjoyed this video you can subscribe or
hit the notification bell and one of
these buttons or watch another video but
you know this thing is you don't um I
mean you don't you don't have to I'm a
dive I'd like it if you did a lot of
effort into it whatever you want